with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
flexible easy data pipelines with cloud
composer then stay tuned because here's
the rewind if you're a company dealing
with loads of complex data then chances
are you deal with a whole set of
computational work flows in your
computing environment for example let's
say you have a lot of on-prem files that
you needed to push up to cloud storage
and each time you did you wanted to load
the data into bigquery and run an ETL
query which notifies the slack channel
when progress is complete with a link to
the logs from the work now traditionally
creating and managing these types of
workflows on Google cloud platform was a
cumbersome operation that ranged from
easy and inflexible like using cron
simple tasks to really complex
frameworks that might require a team of
engineers to build and get right
thankfully cloud composer has recently
been released to general availability to
make all of that a whole lot easier
at its core cloud composer is a
scaleable service built on the open
source project Apache airflow meaning
that you can still focus on authoring
airflow workflows while GCP makes
creating managing and deploying your
workflows much easier it works like this
cloud composer orchestrates your
workflow by using directed acyclic
graphs or DAGs which are the
representation of tasks that airflow
needs to run including all of their
relationships and dependencies involved
and to facilitate this orchestration
composers use Python to let you
dynamically create powerful pipelines
quickly and collaborate alongside anyone
familiar with the language of course
running on Google cloud means that your
tasks have access to the full suite of
Google services including access to the
developer console cloud SDK identity
aware proxy sack driver I am and more
but one of the best things is that cloud
composer gives you the ability to
connect your pipeline through a single
orchestration tool whether your workflow
lives on premises in multiple clouds or
fully within GCP the ability to author
scheduled and monitor your workflows in
a unified manner
means that you can break down the silos
in your environment and focus less on
infrastructure now in the full talk the
speakers give a great example of the
core process of how to use composer
including a live demo of getting a
workflow up and running check out the
full talk linked in the description
below and don't forget to subscribe to
the cloud YouTube channel for more great
next rewind content thanks for watching
[Music]